what we've been looking at so far I kind
of like you know try to move like x
squared plus 5x plus 6 and they're easy
to factorize this is not a trinomial
it doesn't fit your neural patterns but
we've been looking at algebra quite a
lot recently so hopefully the approach
where this is in your head you've got
four terms in other words you've got two
pairs of terms so instead of trying to
come up with like a quadratic formula
factorization you should just pair the
terms up all right sometimes this needs
to be rearranged a little bit but you
kept like giving you doesn't need to be
what common factors like take out
because right and that often by doing
that properly will show you what you
should take out for the next pair which
in this case is just minus 1/2 sine
theta-1 ok so from here I've got these
two in colleagues I'll take them out and
then I've got a closed theta minus 1 as
the other piece okay so then you're
gonna have sine theta equals negative
1/2 cos theta equals 1 and you can go
ahead and you can solve from there but
you guys know how to do that pot yeah we
all get better doing that five you need
to be practice still but like after this
line after this line we've done these
questions to desk so I'm not gonna spend
any money
hmm okay now guys that's the end of the
end of the double but being that I'm not
gonna be here on Friday does anyone need
to be somewhere at recess so that I
can't go through the last two questions
if you need to go then you can go but I
really like to show you five and six
otherwise you will have some significant
trouble with the questions in for G at
the end so is that okay all right but
I'm gonna write this out and immediately
you will see a problem okay number one
the numbers aren't very friendly but
more significantly you got a sign
squared your post square you could swap
either of those out for one minus cos
squared or 1 minus sine squared using
the Pythagorean identity but you kind of
stuck with this guy right you're like
where is he going to go okay so what
this should tell you is that this is
going to be neither a quadratic in sign
nor quadratic in cosign it's gonna be a
quadratic in tan now how do we make it
look like that what you do is you take
all of your terms every single one and
you divide by an appropriate power of
cos you say that again you take every
single turn there's three of them and
you divide them all third by closed or
cos squared or cos cube depending on the
powers that you have here so in this
case I'm gonna divide by cos square
every single term okay so what I'm going
to get on the next line is going to be
sine squared cos squared is fans cred
right here this cause will cancel with
one of the cosines there so you'll end
up with minus 2 tan theta right and then
on the end the clothes squares both
cancel with each other and you get that
okay that's a quadratic in tan you can
factorize that in terms of tan this 10
10 plus this 10 plus that - right and
then you can solve that just like you've
been solving the previous ones okay does
that make sense
can I move on all right now this one I
intentionally a bomb tried to throw in a
bit of a spanner in the works okay have
a look at it let me write it up over
here how many terms are there on the
left hand side how many terms are there
there are four right so you think okay
my approach here to same feed up what I
got Dan what am I got the next side tan
and what's that - - okay you think I
should pair up here and that's a good
way to go
how shall I pair how shall I pick put
put these two together put these two yup
so if I go if I just rewrite this extra
line my okay I'm going to put the two
there and the minus 10 there you can see
it almost there I'll cut you okay let's
take out the sign that's gonna give you
2 plus 10 I'll take out the minus 1 that
would give you 2 plus 10 okay now we get
all the way to be read with this one
you'll see why this gives me same thing
your minus 1 2 plus 10 feet up okay two
branches Science Theater equals 1 tan
theta equals negative 2 now the domain
of tan is all real values of Y so this
is fine this is going to get a solution
reach me calculator and it should tell
you something
awkward like this or you just add 180
okay now you got to be careful because
if you say into your calculator if you
punch in this it will hand you a
negative angle it'll hand you - 6463
something
but that's outside the domain it's not
from naught to 360 right so keeping in
mind that 10 is periodic every how many
degrees hundred days all you do is add
on the Draenei that'll give you an
obtuse solution and then you add another
180 and you'll get a reflux solution
okay so far so good I've done that side
tell me what's the solution to this
ninety degrees so how many solutions are
there counting one two three wrong there
are not three solutions and I want you
to step this is a really important point
it's really important this is in last
year's two unit HSC exam there's one of
the multiple choice it's a great
question why are there three solutions
aha this guy looks so innocuous doesn't
he but he doesn't exist
look this this is not the question it's
the tool that we use to get some
solutions that might be the question
this is the question and it's got
tangent and tan exists here and here and
here it doesn't exist at 90 or 270 it's
clever isn't it there are two solutions
and two only thanks everyone have a
lovely week